before you write anything additional to
explain like the IOA why we dreams
natori right and my answer to that is
let's just have a look around us okay
think about things in nature things like
this things like like this that is
anyone ever seen a starfish in real life
before no way excellent Oh fantastic
yeah you can do it okay
Todd look at this I have our I have one
of these in my house actually I've quite
a few in my house have a look at the
angles coming off the trunk here right
straight the next one look at my mom
she's there are these of their they kind
of like cacti but they're not that
pointy like these are actually quite
soft and look at all of these angles
swirling around look at each like
individual you call these petals maybe
they form an angle and they're all
forming these different angles going
around hey the next one
watch out hello this one what's this
there's a beehive right this is um
incredible little Ricky and bees you
wouldn't think that a lot about maths
but well what about angles right now
it's not just nature that likes ankles
if we just go to the metal okay how will
do this interesting piece of
architecture although the angle is
flying around there the next is a bit
more local have a look at the angles on
this angles in every little spot nook
and cranny seems builds of angles and I
think I have one more yeah that's a fun
one how
angles angles everywhere okay now angles
that's my lost H other angles are
everywhere and angles are really
interested that's why we're interested
in angles okay sorry under this heading
right I'd like you to UM get a rule
about don't you get a rule if you
haven't got one I am going to I'll leave
this one in English I'll leave that one
there with your ruler oh that's a shame
doesn't matter go away with your ruler
what I'd like you to draw for me is well
I'd like you to draw an angle for me but
I'm gonna show you the kind of angled
like your jaw so we all have a similar
if you're a few soft and if you could
make it make this little angle actually
about the size of the palm of your hand
don't make it any smaller because we're
gonna draw some stuff on this and ladies
it is too small I hope you drew it in
pencil okay if you don't have a rule
lock I think I may have one or two
delenn but you may have to borrow for
the friend catch okay sir with your rule
there we are going to do they look few
things on you because in mathematics
I've told you this before
language is palpable right if you have
language that you can use to describe
something you can't explain to someone
else communicate things about it so this
is enable but we want to be able to talk
about it and describe it so the first
thing I wanna say is well this angle
needs a name right I'm going to call
this angle what shall i polar
yes how about I'm gonna call this angle
because I like this name okay before the
sacred dance okay now you'll find often
right we have particular points on a
time you see this before and we give
them letters so you can take rule of
this D and this n this n now this
particular angle starts here going on
here and then ends there you need three
points to make a name don't you okay so
what you're saying this use and one
saying angle down we have a symbol that
we use in fact it looks a lot like this
this is our symbol for an angle okay you
can see it kind of looks like an L
that's just sort of really really bender
this is there okay now Dan is the way
that I would probably then to what you
can see that's not the only way we call
it remember how I started up here right
what's to say you don't start from down
here and you'll still make the same
angle so you can come here if you really
want I think it's time but you can come
in now
- it's the same angle he's pretty cool
at ball because they don't have to
but then maybe be one or two now I won't
add on something and I want you to put
in a different color to make bread okay
you can see the most importance of these
points of D and then the most important
one is where the angle is happening
right that's in here at a right a is
like a critical piece so some people
some people just call him angle side Hey
right now I'm going to discourage you
from writing it like that I'll tell you
why in a minute but I want you to see it
because if some people call on that you
want to know what they're talking you
want to recognize what they mean right
I'll give you an example shortly of why
I don't think this is such a great idea
for you I think I'll Dan ahead are
better but nonetheless sometimes you'll
see it just one matter and they mean
that's the yeah well I'm staying or read
if you've got a little color there this
describes in these bits and pieces right
these two things you they kind of look
like two arms stretching out right it's
your arms stretching out to someone over
here so because they kind of look like
two arms
we call them right this angle every
angle has two of the top bottom one and
left one of the right whichever way
that's the most important the the part
that forms it I think like we said
before the most important in the angle
is that one right but what way the MU
actually happening so because he's
important beginners well it's called the
vertex of the rule of vertex there's a
very fancy dress it makes you sense the
plural is vertices
okay so you can have one vertex there's
one vertex or if you're just wearing a
whole bunch of angles you will have a
whole bunch of vertices
different shape their vertices we just
mean so that's the vertex and the
previous is one last piece to indicate
that an angle is happening all right I'm
going to put you a little off yeah that
arc indicates right this is the size I'm
interested in fact that size there
that's how definition for angle I really
wanted to give you a picture first